[Music]
let's go to tori in
charlotte north carolina and charlotte
what's up
hey how are you done so good are you
i'm doing well what are you doing and
what are y'all doing there y'all having
fun
yeah we are having fun it's a little
chilly these days but
i am a little upset that uh nashville
mls soccer team just beat our new mls
soccer team getting started now the
other day well i'm i'm i'm a little
upset that somebody mentioned that
communist sport on my show i'm just
totally kidding
i'm not listen i'm not great at soccer
it's a lot of running and kicking and
those guys all look super
can i just tell you this i was in brazil
with my wife okay and
you know how like
in the states you can drive by like a
city park and they're playing basketball
um
you know they play basketball until late
in the evening whatever well in brazil
it was a thousand degrees it was so hot
so beautiful and it's like tropic it's
unbelievable and
my wife was doing some research at a was
helping some schools whatever and so i
was just on my own
and
i drove by at late at night one of those
it looked like a soccer i mean it looked
like a tennis court like a basketball
court except they were playing soccer
oh my
it was the most incredible
it was everyone was beautiful all of
them were beautiful and i thought this
sport's probably not for me i need a
sport like fighting where everyone's not
that attractive it's cool so good for
you hey that's awesome tell your team to
pick it up they're terrible all right
let's go i know so what's up tori okay
well i am
a brand new labor and delivery nurse and
i love everything about it
um they're really really good days you
get to see awesome babies and crazy
stories and miracles and there's really
hard days too and
there's rare days that we lose babies
and babies don't make it or are born
not living
and i just feel like i'm not grieving
these babies effectively so what are
some tools that can help me
improve and grieve more effectively what
a great question
number one thank you for being there
that's such a gift wow
um what drew you did that work
i um
spent time overseas and
i worked with medical mission teams in
ecuador actually
um
in like indigenous communities in the
mountains and it was just such a clear
picture to me that like no matter what
corner of the world i go to health care
is needed
and they're birthing babies like if i
went into some specialties they you know
i might not be able to do it wherever in
the whole world yeah they're not doing
knee replacements everywhere yeah okay
very cool that's right what a great
intricate like oncology treatments or
whatever yeah so
um i love it i love maternity i love
getting to meet women at that place and
that vulnerability and supporting them
and honestly it's it's so hard i don't
love
working with a woman when her baby
doesn't make it but it is a privilege to
be with her in those moments too you
know um
so what makes you think you're not
grieving well
i um
before working in labor and delivery i
worked in oncology and i worked at a
nursing home and
so it's not like i haven't seen death at
work um and it's not like
some lives are more important than
others um
yeah
it's so different there's just something
about babies um
and
we work you know after they're born
um
cleaning them you know having parents
hold them
taking pictures of them and it's just
very very hands-on and elaborate and
i've just been finding that
in eight months of working there it's
happened four times to me and every time
i messed up for days
like connection with people is hard
there's little things that happen that
just put me in like a puddle on the
floor and
um it's just surprising to me like how
debilitating it is again when that's not
something that's very new in my world
but
um like death in general yeah so i've
i've talked about it some on the show i
i pride myself on being able to walk
into the most bonker situations and yeah
um
twice
in my career i left my crisis so this
stuff i would do after hours i left my
partner and both times i said i gotta go
i have to step out of here which is a
big no-no
except i came to learn that it's a gift
and i'll tell you about it in a second
but
um
i had a little baby girl when josephine
my daughter was young she was one or two
um i went to one call that was at an er
and it was with a tiny tiny youngster
and
i'll never forget i saw the youngster's
arm through a crowd of people there
people working on her and my job was to
go tell the parents what had happened
and to sit with the parents while they
try to keep this little girl alive
and
it was i saw six inches of her arm i
just saw her arm through a crack of
people and my body reacted in a way that
i was un i was caught off guard by
yeah and i found myself turning to leave
and like
like you i i would never do that you
know what i mean it was weird it was
almost i was grieving my own body like
what are you doing
and yeah my partner janiece who i just
love she looked at me and said what are
you doing i said i gotta go i can't be
here and she's like you're leaving me
and i said i'm telling you right now i
gotta go and she's like get out of here
and we talked later and she said i'm so
glad you had the courage to tell me then
i said that's never happening again like
i'm gonna flex and snap into a slim gym
and listen to some jaco podcast or
whatever like i'm gonna be all in and
then
um
i was a part of a situation where there
was a mom telling her little babies that
their daddy had taken and died by
suicide
and that was another one when the kids
started crying i i turned and said i
gotta go i left and for me two things
were important number one
was knowing
your body knows as well or better than
you do
and
i had a little girl at the time now i
could do it now i would be fine but at
the time my body was recognizing those
stories running simultaneously and it
overloaded the system
and so
um
and then here's the other thing i had to
develop really robust processes for
handling that stuff you know what i mean
because i can't just leave every time
same as your job
so
when you say your body is
like
you're just a puddle for four days give
me some very specific things what does
that mean
um
i remember it was actually just last
week i had my most recent one and
i remember just being there like trying
to cook dinner with my husband and i
don't even remember what we were talking
about but there was just something
that set me off and i just had to and
i'm i'm not i'm really not like that at
all um
and even like my husband's coming he's
been like whenever something happens
with like our family or whatever you're
you know
like i i'm a rock kind of person but
i'll just have to disappear and have to
like get out of the room and like
take a walk or something and um what
does it feel about it what does it feel
like
really heavy yeah
um it feels like
it like every time it happens it's like
costing a really deep part of me you
know yeah put me there and be with the
family um
yeah it just feels like every single
time i i'm giving a part of me away and
it's it's heavy it's really heavy yeah
or sometimes it's giving yourself part
of your way
i remember a few situations where i felt
like a part of me was taken
i didn't give permission for it i didn't
ask for that yeah when i show up to
situations and you know there's people
who have passed away here and there's
dead people here to people here i chose
to walk into those rooms and i'm okay
giving up a piece of myself in that
moment because i've got
other people who are right there with me
whether they're my partners or my the
greatest supervisor ever dr young
who are there to refill right
it's when i go into a situation and i
feel like a part of me gets taken that
that's that's where it's unnerving right
that's it yeah
so um
i'm gonna walk through a couple things
that i did and that i still do
and then leave you with um
one cool truth and one really hard one
okay yeah
all right so here's the first one
um and this by the way if you're
listening to this and think well gosh
i'm glad i'm not a like a delivery nurse
i'm not a trauma nurse or i'm not a
whatever
everybody experiences this stuff and
these are moments when your body
overrides your system that's trauma when
whatever's going on your body says whoa
we can't handle that and some people
fight it and some will run from it and
some people just go completely numb and
some people are able to go through the
motions and then
it shows up in it i call it this is a
gross word but we call it leakage right
if you don't deal with it it will find a
way out and it's usually at a real
inopportune time right like your husband
just gets home and he leans in to kiss
you and you just start crying and throw
the spatula at him and he's like what
what happened
right it comes out at weird places or
you're giving a talk and also you just
start weeping and you can't get it back
right so here's a couple things um oh
one last question sorry do you have
young kids
no i yeah i've not been pregnant yet and
i think
that's another part of it is just like
it's very very easy to put myself in
those potential shoes you know yes yes
yes yes okay yeah
so
one thing i did and you've heard me say
this probably every show since the show
started
is whenever i would show up
to
be with somebody who had just passed and
the loved ones that were left whether
that was at a hospital with a
one-year-old or a six month old or a
two-year-old or i was showing up to a
house like you mentioned with a 98 year
old who had just passed away from you
know congestive heart failure and i was
with his widow right
whatever it was if i left that house
and i could tell it was still hanging on
me i wrote that person a letter
and i told them who i was i told them
that i was gonna be there to love their
family
and that i was gonna make sure that i
did my best to take care of them and i
was so grateful for the time they got
spit on this earth and i wished them
well
and wherever they were going
and
but it was a moment of here's what i'm
doing i'm taking a body that has become
dysregulated it's been overwhelmed by
trauma and i am intentionally bringing
it back online
i'm letting my body know
yes we see this happened i am in control
i'm talking to this person and using
their name if i have it and then i'm
gonna set this down and there's a highly
therapeutic process
that just goes with that and there were
times i wept there were times i couldn't
it was a paragraph and that was it it
was fine and there's other times i wrote
and wrote and wrote and wrote and wrote
and those became some of my most
prized possessions because there were
letters to
like a lost child there were letters to
a teenager who died by suicide and left
his mom bewildered right
but it ended up being about me
being able to reclaim that part that was
taken from me
and it's a 30 minute practice it's an
hour practice you do it by yourself and
my guess is it's it would be really
healing for you
yeah the second thing is
this is hard but when you see that
happening
when you recognize
that someone's about to give birth to a
child who's passed away already or when
that baby is born and this happened with
my son
you you make eye contact with all the
other nurses and everybody knows this is
a big deal this one's scary my son had a
knot in the umbilical cord
and it wasn't it wasn't cinched it was
one of the most incredible things i've
ever seen
but i noticed having been in a lot of
those situations i noticed all the
nurses how they reacted and i knew
something was wrong right
um
one of the tendencies is to pull away
from mom and dad from that single mom
sitting there from the mom and the dad
and the grandma and everybody what's
happening was happening
this is gonna sound bonkers
but lean into it
yeah get closer to mom or dad
get skin-to-skin contact hold hands if
it's appropriate if you're able to if
it's welcome
hug put your hands on the baby if it's
at all possible
go into it and give your body a chance
to process this thing not just rip it
from it
okay
and what the tendency is when you walk
into a house and everyone's weeping so
loud is to be like whoa i'm not wanted
here
that's exactly where you got to step in
now someone may say get your hands off
me i don't want to touch anybody and
they're screaming and yelling and that's
hard and it's scary and all those things
and then obviously you're going to honor
what somebody tells you most of the time
somebody will hug you until you can't
breathe
or they will squeeze your hand until you
feel like it's going to come off right
there's something about leaning into
that instead of leaning out the third
thing that was really important for me
and again i i mean i had the single
greatest supervisor boss friend mentor
gonna call him dr andy young he changed
my life man
um but after the heavy ones he would
call me
and it might be 2 30 in the morning 3 30
morning um how are you you doing okay
um just want to check in on you what'd
you see and he would always ask what did
you see and there was something about
telling somebody else here's what i just
saw that again like writing it down gets
out of my body so here's what i want you
to do i want you to have a couple of
friends that you can call
day or night
and you all can do that for each other
you can have a text code that's like
text five five five five that means one
of us needs to talk right now
and then y'all can get on each other's
radar and you can just tell somebody
through tears and weeping and sobbing
and snot here's what i just saw here's
what just happened
and there's something about getting out
and sharing that burden with you as
david kessler says grief demands a
witness you got someone's got to hear it
and see it with you okay
and then here's the last thing
or the last two things
when that
thought lightning bolts into your head
of that baby laying there
or when they you know you've seen them
do that um
it's unbelievable it's almost
disassociative when they're doing the
um it's a it's it's like a cpr thing but
it's that little bitty squeeze thing
they're trying to get a breath back
and that little bitty chest going up and
down it's one of the most heartbreaking
things you can watch
for me it haunts me
i will see that one again
and
what david kessler talks about in his
book is so phenomenal is
i can control my thoughts and the moment
that picture of that little baby who's
just passed away or that mother who is a
different kind of scream when a mother
loses her baby it's it's something
that's very unique
and when that you know what i'm talking
about you've seen that i do yeah
um
it's easy for that to lightning bolt
back in our heads and then we just
sit and think about it over and over and
over it's our brain's way of protecting
us so that this never happens to us
again
and what we have is a moment right then
when that happens to say i'm out not
doing that off not doing it stop and i'm
gonna think about something else whether
it's a mother i remember laughing
whether it's a healthy baby whether it's
um a hug that i'm giving that father
who's weeping there i'm gonna
intentionally replace that negative
thought with something positive right
away and over time you'll learn to do
that easier and easier and easier and
scott now i've done it for so long it's
just instantaneous okay but it's
something you practice here's the final
thing
there may come a moment where you have
to look in the mirror sit with your
husband and say i love love love this
work
but this part of this of this is not for
me
and that would be hard and i'll be
heartbreaking i don't think that's where
you are
i think you you sound a lot like where i
was where i had to i was like oh i found
my body's limits i've gotta dig deeper
and i've gotta find new tools that i
don't have
um but i do have people that worked in
the crisis team with me that ultimately
said i gotta go like i can't keep going
into these situations um and so knowing
your boundaries is really important
okay and yeah you're not broke and you
didn't fail it's just your body's saying
this is what we can handle kind of like
like not everyone can be a lineman right
not everyone in a football game because
they'll just get crushed or like in your
silly sport that only scores one point
after 11 hours of playing or whatever
like not everybody can be a goalie right
not everybody can be a center forward
and so you got at some point you got to
know like hey this i love medical stuff
like but man the maternity ward's not
for me i'm gonna go do something else
hope i don't think that's where you are
but just keep that in the back of your
mind there okay so i just threw a lot of
issues isn't that helpful
that's really helpful i really
appreciate it awesome here's would be a
great gift
yeah i would love for you to
write a letter to the little baby that
passed recently
and i'd love to mail you you to mail us
a copy of it
and if you'll mail us a copy of it i'll
read it on the air
i can do that i think the world would
benefit from hearing
how much you love somebody
how much you love somebody else's baby
and i want you to hang on the line i'm
going to send you a copy of my brand new
book on your past change your future
that has an entire chapter on grieving
an entire chapter on forgiveness an
entire chapter on how to move forward so
hang on the line we're going to send you
a free copy of that um thank you so so
so much for the call
um man you're awesome hey thank you so
much for being in the lives of our
families and mothers and fathers and
kids and good folks as you hear in the
news
these nurses these nurses these nurses
i'll tell you what i've seen them i've
stood shoulder to shoulder with them
these nurses
they are the adhesive that holds our
communities together